لا يزال الخطر على البشر منخفضًا ، لكن
أحدث انتشار لأنفلونزا الطيور قتل
عددًا قياسيًا من الطيور الداجنة التي
ترفع العلم الأحمر أو تسبب بعض
القلق بين الباحثين في الصحة العامة
والمحققين السريريين حول
إمكانية رؤية المزيد من الحالات في
البشر.  أكثر من 6300
حالة معروفة من إنفلونزا الطيور في جميع الولايات الخمسين
وفقًا لمراكز السيطرة على الأمراض والوقاية منها ، من المحتمل أن يكون هناك
العديد من الحالات غير المعروفة في 47 ولاية ، حيث
كان هناك تفشي متعدد بين
الدواجن التي تضم أكثر من 58
ونصف مليون طائر ،
وتقول وزارة الزراعة الأمريكية إنها أيضًا  يظهر في
بعض أسراب الفناء الخلفي غير التجارية
بالإضافة إلى الفيروس الذي يصيب المزيد من الطيور
وقد يتسبب في تحور ماثيو بينكر ، مدير علم
الفيروسات الإكلينيكي في Mayo Clinic.
الولايات المتحدة ،
بما في ذلك حيوانات الفقمة ، الدببة الثعلب التي تم
التعرف عليها على أنها مصابة
بسلالة الخل تقول إن الفيروس ينتشر
فقط من خلال الاتصال المباشر مع
حيوان مصاب لمنع التعرض
للابتعاد عن الطيور النافقة إذا رأيت طائرًا
قد مات على أرضك في
ممتلكاتك.  لن أصعد وأمسك بالطائر
لأن ما نراه هو أنه في
حالات قليلة من إنفلونزا الطيور بين
البشر كان هذا هو الطريق للصحة
دقيقة أنا آندي جاثر